الخارجيه الامريكي قال ان هناك حاجه الى
فتح المزيد من المعابر على الحدود السوريه
التركيه واضاف انه لا عذر ابدا لعدم المضي
قدما في هذا الصدد اما المندوبه الامريكيه
بمجلس الامن ليندا فقد شددت على ضروره ان
يراقب المجلس تنفيذ اتفاق فتح معبرين
اضافيين لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
سوريا
لان اي تقدم لايصال المساعدات الى الشعب
السوري يعد امرا ضروريا
الى ضمان عدم ايقاف المساعدات بقرار لمجلس
الامن من شانه ان يضمن ذلك ما نخطط القيام
به حاليا هو مراقبه تنفيذ الاتفاق بجديه
اذا كانت المساعده تتدفق بطريقه غير مقيده
وحصل الاشخاص على المساعده
التي فسيكون ذلك جيدا لكن علينا ان نراقب
لنرى ما سيحدث استغرق اتخاذ هذا القرار
سبعه اياما للسماح بفتح الحدود كان ينبغي
اتخاذ هذا القرار في اليوم الاول